plus on est alors vous allez participer
à la fête de la musique à travers la
nuit du rock sur antenne 2 ce soir mais
auparavant je vous propose est dégoûté
de sorte que vous puissiez réagir
peut-être on entendra la voix du batteur
richard kolinka s'est pas beaucoup
exprimé jusqu'à maintenant
le chanteur a l'air d'être aussi le cosy
ans de la troupe on écoute monsieur
auquel il entend tout ce que j'ai
entrepris
les études mon travail personnel j'ai
toujours beaucoup les q2 un
environnement musical aujourd'hui de
cette fête nationale de la musique bien
je crois que ce qui est attendu c'est
que les centaines de milliers de deux
musiciens amateurs et professionnels se
mettent en mouvement et quand je discute
attendu je sais déjà
ayant moi-même se rencontrer ce matin
sortant de chez moi des jeunes qui vont
dire on vous donne rendez vous tout à
leur place square du temple ans on y
vient avec les batteries on sera là avec
des tas d'instruments que nous avons
fabriquer nous mêmes
et d'après les informations que j'ai
partout dans tout le village dans toutes
les communes de france les jeunes et les
moins jeunes se préparent depuis des
semaines à ce grand événement et ce
grand événement ce ne sont pas seulement
les manifestations organisées qui auront
lieu ici ou là notamment à paris c'est
la multitude d'initiatives individuelles
des sirènes du port de marseille au
bourdon du beffroi d'orléans du concert
de baisers qui nous sera ce square
offert au palais royal en passant par
des tas de choses que nous ne
connaissons pas encore et que nous
découvrirons cette nuit
ce n'est pas un moyen aussi de faire
oublier la politique de rigueur mais non
je crois qu'au contraire la politique
d'ensemble du gouvernement une politique
qui dans la finalité principale c'est de
changer la vie ni d'apporter un peu de
bonheur d'apporter de la tendresse
d'apporter notre société de l'invention
de l'imagination le reste de votre
journée d'un très musical lamielle
oui enfin j'ai je suis jugé au fond être
plutôt un touriste qui vais aller
d'endroit en endroit car beaucoup d'amis
m'ont demandé de venir leur rendre
visite
situé à peu près où je dois aller dans
beaucoup de rues de paris dans la
banlieue parisienne j'espère pouvoir
aller à tous les rendez-vous qu'on m'a
donné en attendant vous jouez pour nous
oui mais là je le pianoter un tout petit
ou là comme un amateur
jack lang a ajouté qu'il emporte qu'il
avait emporté un disque de vous en chine
parce qu'il voulait vous promouvoir en
chine vous avez des nouvelles de la
chine et que j'espère y aller ray
charles ai pas parlé j'espère lui l'a
mené à un seul dit non à plusieurs
si les nuages ja on va arrêter de parler
de l'image de la france que vous
représentez dans le monde simplement